die politik hat die letzten zwei jahre
verpasst hier vorzusorgen für diese zeit
jetzt gekommen ist es wurden stellen
abgebaut das wurde wirklich asozialen
mit leuten umgegangen haben wir so ein
paar beispiele und ich glaube halt jetzt
die kurve wieder zu bekommen in diesem
jahr unmöglich weil es gibt
sicherheitsüberprüfungen also dieses
projekt was hier zu haben mit
ausländischen mitarbeitern hier
unterstützen sollen was jetzt auch schon
wieder runter gefahren wurde da reden
wir über zeiträume dann ist der urlaub
vorbei und wenn man so sieht dieses
dieses koffer chaos zum beispiel dass
das staut sich immer weiter an und zu
sagen ich nehme flüge aus dem system um
den druck rauszunehmen naja wenn ich
jetzt 2000 flüge habe 180 mann pro oder
von einem menschen halt pro flugzeug das
das mache ich denn mit denen also da ist
ja kein ersatz in diesem moment da und
wir staunen diese probleme immer weiter
auf und die letzten zwei jahre was so
wir hatten immer fix gehabt also
geradezu den ferien da wurde halt mal
für zwei wochen richtig durchgeackert
und so auf dem rücken der beschäftigten
aber es funktioniert irgendwie und dann
hieß es danach wir haben es geschafft
die die leute haben es ja geschafft ist
doch alles gar kein problem wir stehen
gut da so und jetzt
kollabiert dieses system einfach und ich
glaube viel wird halt auch wieder auf
corona geschoben dass die leute krank
sind und so ich glaube ganz viele leute
sind krank wenn sie diesem druck einfach
nicht mehr aushalten wir haben beispiele
aus frankfurt vom flughafen wo wirklich
mitarbeitende
angegriffen werden also da wird eine
schuhe ausgezogen über den kopf gezogen
wir haben ein beispiel da wurde der
monitor rausgerissen beim check-in
agenten und nun über den kopf gezogen
und jetzt jetzt fing man schon an die
lufthansa neue security personal
einzustellen die die leute unterstützt
und ja aber irgendwann ist halt der
kanal voll und dann ist man krank und
dann ist man nicht nur einen oder zwei
tage krank dennoch ein für längere zeit
krank und wie gesagt wie will man da die
kurve kriegen und ich bin halt selber
lufthansa-mitarbeiter wird ein letzte
woche auch schon gesagt dass ich das
immer von carsten spohr wurde
der schöne entschuldigung und carsten
spohr stellt sich dann hin in diese
sendung also wer hier immer nur
kritisiert und immer nur irgendwie gegen
alles ist und nicht mitziehen will und
nicht mehr diese spirits lufthanseat zu
sein der soll dort den kündigen und alle
leute die die sich aufregen die kritik
üben die machen das weil sie etwas
verbessern wollen und zu sagen dann geht
doch bitte einfach also wie wie
abgehoben ist dieser sie ja und meine
persönliche meinung ist wenn wir es
jetzt mal beim fußballclub vergleichen
würden der trainer gehört ausgetauscht
und diese woche gab es eine
außerordentliche aufsichtsratssitzung
das thema war und so wie ich gehört habe
es geht immer nur darum die mitarbeiten
unseren krank das ist das problem nein
es wurden tausende flüge in den markt
gestellt die man einfach nicht bedienen
kann und es ist ja auch so wenn man sich
die
anteilsverhältnisse anguckt der
flughafen frankfurt ist im größten teil
landesbesitz
die die lufthansa hat anteile eine
fraport und wenn man dann sagt naja uns
wurde immer gesagt man schafft das schon
wo sind die aufsichtsratsgremien wer
kontrolliert das anders sehen wir da mal
ganz zarten finger auch in die wunde
möchte ich auch jemanden die in die
runde geben diese frage wer hat schuld
wir blicken ein deutscher flughäfen da
werden die koffer nicht gefunden da
können menschen nicht wegfliegen endlich
urlaub nach zwei jahren kann diesen
urlaub hat man sich verdient wer trägt
die schuld daran ein stück weit muss
immer sagen sind wir da durch corona aus
einer ziemlich tiefen wohlstands
illusion gerissen worden denn wir haben
und da sind die flughäfen glaube ich ein
paradebeispiel wir haben eine ganze
menge dienstleistung uns immer gegönnt
wollten sie aber eigentlich nicht so
richtig bezahlen und dann lagert man die
sicherheitskontrolle aus frankfurt ist
es glaube ich irgendwann der
bundespolizei das ist eine ausnahme ja
so die bei anderen seite auch gern
unterstützen kupfer transporte
verschiedene andere dienstleistungen im
umfeld des flugbetriebes werden dann
ausgelagert an firmen wo man dann
geringere löhne bezahlt wir im prinzip
wollen wir die dienstleistung haben aber
sie sollten möglichst wenig kosten und
das ist ein system was in dem moment
kollabiert wo die bedingungen nicht mehr
optimal in das war bei corona so und da
hat man die leute nach hause geschickt
prima kann man schnell kündigen sind ja
nicht bei der lufthansa angestellt gut
die fehlen jetzt und zum teil sind sie
nicht wieder gekommen weil sie beim
kellnern mehr verdienen ein ganzer aller
art der illusion hingegeben des billig
reisens billig flugtickets mal kurz für
ein paar euro rüber dahin klinge dahin
fliegen sind diese zeiten vorbei muss
ich das vielleicht auch verändern
befindet bedeutet aber auch gleichzeitig
dass viele menschen die sich den urlaub
schon nicht so gut leisten können dann
überhaupt nicht mehr flugreisen wie ich
glaube wir müssen diesen wurden dem
mittelweg finden also ein ticket für 20
euro dass das funktioniert nicht allein
wenn ich sehe welche flughafengebühren
ich habe luftsicherheit und alles und
ich mal überlege das was kostet dieses
produkt flugzeug dieses produkt fliegen
also ein a 321 wenn wir neu
ausgelieferte kostet mit 110 millionen
euro das geld noch reinkommen wir haben
die spritkosten hier natürlich auch
gestiegen sind und alles das sind
gebühren ich weiß nicht auf dem flug
nach mallorca was aktuell jetzt ein
fairer preis wäre aber wahrscheinlich
schon so 300 euro ja und dann schreiben
sie alle auf das ist viel zu viel ja
aber jetzt überlegt doch mal ich sehe es
ja die die parkhäuser am flughafen sind
voll da zahlt man 150 euro die woche um
sein auto zu parken möchte aber nicht
300 euro für die namen bezahlen sondern
es gibt auch für 20 euro das geht
einfacher wenn sie das fahren weil sie
haben mit vielen menschen kontakt die
können sich sicherlich meine 300 euro
leisten für den flug nach also erstmal
finde ich zb ich selber so der fisch
stinkt vom kopf ab da sind wir nämlich
bei dem wenn ich so was nicht abgehoben
ist sowas arrogantes sind ignorantes
höre das könnte ich ja dann auf unser
land um bündeln und sagen dagegen dem
ziemlich passt der soll das land
verlassen also dann wird die lösung ist
man dass jeder der kritik übt ich meine
weiße deutschland habe eine einstellung
dass immer der mehr missachtet der die
missstände anspricht als der dänische
verantworten hat ja das ist aber falsch
denn so was da ist und jetzt sind
hausgemachte probleme die pandemie alle
hat man weggeschmissen japan schnell
sind ersetzt worden jetzt steht man da
aber die menschen einmal im jahr in
urlaub fliegen wollen und dann so
ausartet dann weiß ich nicht 100 und ich
sehe die gewaltbereitschaft wir haben
eine extreme zunahme der der fallenden
hemmschwellen bei kindern wachsen der
haut in den monitor über den kopf oder
geprügelt sich da
überall ich mag das extremen die
pandemie hat besonders den kindern einen
immensen schaden angerichtet wir haben
noch nie so viele jetzt einfach mal
butter bei die fische kinderschutz ist
mein thema er eine zunahme von über 56
prozent von kinderpornografie eine
zunahme von über 10% gewalt gegen kinder
eine zunahme von fast 6%
kindesmissbrauch eine zunahme von 400%
suiziden und wenn das haben wir übrigens
lauterbach und co alles vorher gesagt
wenn ihr die kinder aus der schule
nehmen dann werden die zahlen steigen
sagt keine passiert und jetzt geht es
darum diese zahlen wieder zu
relativieren aber wenn es um die zahl
von der lauterbacher gibt die werden im
gold gemeißelt ich verstehe das nicht
jetzt reden wir schon wieder über
mögliche maßnahmen das sind alles zum
thema gewährt gekommen da nicht mehr
raus aber wir wir schaffen uns stück für
stück wenn ich ja immer so ein bisschen
polemisch ist stück für stück ab und
sind alles selbst gemacht der polemik
ich warte immer auf jemanden in der
politik der gewisse orientierung
übernimmt und vielleicht ist der wunsch
glaube ich weiß nicht aber es ist
einfach so es wird nicht besser und wenn
ich jetzt auch holland gucke thema kommt
janka nicht kann ich euch sagen dass ich
bestimmte dinge lese und ich möchte das
nicht erleben was in holland gerade
passiert hat die politik da den kopf
verloren sieht sie das nicht sie sind in
der frage waren die wirtschaft kommen
aber jetzt gerade das war schon ein
chaos kann man glaube ich relativ viel
sagen dass dort die politik lenken kann
und auch versucht jetzt zu helfen
also ein kleines flughafen die politik
kann die flughäfen also die flughäfen
werden ja nicht von von der
bundespolitik betrieben oder oder wir
unterhalten auch keine
fluggesellschaften also dieser dieser
vorwurf den den kann man nicht an
politik richten aber auf der anderen
seite wird jetzt viel getan um zu helfen
diesen stau zu geraten weil es wurden
keine menschen weggeworfen wie sie
gerade gesagt haben dass finnischen
hafen ausdruck meiner so lassen sich auf
diese menschen haben einfach eine andere
arbeit gefunden in dem vermutlich weil
ich stellen abgebaut den punkt ich aber
mal machen um ihr haben wir haben jetzt
eine situation in der flughafen
arbeitskräfte suchen in einer
gesellschaft die nahezu
vollbeschäftigung hat an der stelle und
da findet man keine leute weil die
einfach untergekommen sind die arbeiten
jetzt sonst wo die arbeiten zum beispiel
in der gastronomie die arbeiten in
hotels die arbeiten bei
sicherheitsservices die externen sind
und wenn man jetzt diese leute wieder da
rausnehmen an die flughäfen setzen dann
sehen sie ja sonst wo wieder an am ende
lagen es wurde nicht nur am ende des
tages das tatsächlich auch die frage
dass wir ein einwanderungsland sind und
dass wir uns auch dazu bekennen müssen
dass wir auch ein modernes
einwanderungsgesetz an der stelle
brauchen dass wir leben und mit leben
füllen da wurde in der vergangenheit
viel verpasst aber wenn jetzt die
trendwende dadurch kommt dass wir krisen
haben und dann darin auch die chance
liegt dann können wir was gutes draus
machen das geht nicht schnell da haben
sie recht für den sommer jetzt akut
haben wir ein großes problem an den
flughäfen das lässt sich nicht
wegdiskutieren
und das sagt ja auch jeder der
beteiligten aber es wird alles getan um
zu versuchen die die lücke da raus zu
nehmen ich sehe darin auch früher machen
müssen ich sehe auch laden da
reingepumpt sind ja sie haben eben
gesagt warum wurden die flüge zum
beispiel gebucht ich habe mich ja da
auch schlau gemacht wir führen ja auch
gespräche das hängt einfach damit
zusammen dass die fluggesellschaften
sehr sehr früh die slots buchen müssen
als die des lochs gebucht haben das war
irgendwann vor weihnachten da hatten wir
die delta variante die gegenüber in die
omikron variante da konnte man nicht
absehen dass sich der flugbetrieb so
entwickeln wird zum sommer hin wie er
sich jetzt entwickelt hat das ist eine
entschuldigung die uns gegenüber von den
verantwortlichen entgegengebracht wird
um bei politik für verständnis für die
situation zu werben weil wir werden ja
auch angesprochen wie jetzt wir wären ja
darauf angesprochen und sollen den
menschen erklären warum das chaos jetzt
herrscht und am ende des tages hilft
diese erklärung vielleicht ein bisschen
um es zu verstehen aber sie hilft ja
nicht aktuell wenn man in der schlange
steht und angst hat sagen ich habe ein
sehr gutes beispiel an der stelle am 23
dezember 2020 haben mitarbeiter der
wisag in frankfurt ihre kündigung
erhalten aber wie sagt gesagt hat der
markt wird nicht mehr zurückkommen wir
brauchen diese mitarbeitenden nicht mehr
wir haben die politik eingeschaltet wir
sind wirklich an hier an die höchsten
stellen gegangen und man hat sich
weggeduckt man hat einfach die augen
zugemacht und was noch schlimmer war an
diesem fall des wurde das waren ältere
kollegen die schon lange dabei waren
natürlich die alten besseren verträge
hatten sie wurden nach und nach in die
büros geholt und sagen komm ich geb dir
neuen arbeitsvertrag bei einer anderen
gmbh du kommst auch irgendwann wieder
ist das gar kein problem aber du musst
erst mal dahin und wie schön wir lassen
das hatten wir schwarz weist das hat die
politik schwarz auf weiß bekommen und
man hat es ignoriert
das ist eine ganze menge baustellen
jetzt eine reise bei solchen bei solchen
entscheidungen finde ich eigentlich
immer ein bisschen schade dass vorstände
und verantwortliche in der wirtschaft
dann nur anhand der zahlen irgendwie
gemessen werden aber für solche
gravierenden fehleinschätzungen dass der
markt nicht zurückkommt war damals schon
ein quatsch jeder wusste dass mit jedem
monat pandemie der druck steigt
irgendwie wieder raus wieder zu
kompensieren der markt würde zurück
kommt das wusste man also wer so ein
quatsch geredet hat und darauf
wirtschaftliche entscheidung
aufgefordert gehört heute gefeiert das
andere ist migrationspolitik haben sie
schon gesagt ja gut das war aber auch
bis vor kurzem wirklich ein chaos ohne
ende die kanzlerin hat knapp zwei
millionen leute ins land gelassen 2015
16 die stehen aber heute zu großen
teilen dem arbeitsmarkt nicht zur
verfügung wir haben über jahre immer die
falsche migration gehabt die
facharbeiter lücke wuchs und wir hatten
trotzdem eine illegale migration über
die grenzen die dann am ende im
duldungsstatus schutzstatus das heißt
wir haben also keine arbeitsmigration
sondern wir hatten einen schutz
migration die hilft uns aber auf dem
arbeit mache ich weiter und das dritte
was er sagt ist natürlich wirklich
dramatisch wenn man sich überlegt dass
selbst in den hoch zeiten der pandemie
es anhörungen bei der kanzlerin gab habe
ich selbst mitgemacht wo dann
kinderpsychologen gesagt hat wir haben
eine ein anstieg der suizidrate bei
kindern und jugendlichen um 30
und anja schönen dank für ihren beitrag
und jetzt haben wir noch jemand von
jugendhilfe frankfurt was ist denn ihre
erfahrung und dann wurde das alles zu
holen und in der schutzart kleine lok
und es gab keine bereitschaft die korona
maßnahmen in irgendeiner art und weise
abzugleichen mit den schäden die durch
die korona maßnahmen verursacht und das
war gab es einfach nicht weil die
kanzlerin ganz klar sagte schutz wir
machen dich lockdown und das muss und
wer sich da nicht beugte der kriegt
neuer ärger in eine
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und
wir sind dafür ja auch selbst stark
kritisiert worden als preis stimmen
wird eine dabei waren da immer skeptisch
ich meine in der ersten welle wusste man
es auch nicht besser das war ein
lerneffekt nur als 2020 corona losging
musste natürlich keiner da hat man auch
also ich glaube da muss man auch
nachsichtig sein jens spahn hat auch
richtigerweise damals gesagt man wird
sich auch viel verzeihen müssen aber
dass es nachher so viel wird und die
schulen dann auch in summe so lange
geschlossen waren das war ein
riesenfehler das darf nie wieder
passieren jetzt schon wieder eher
quatsch will schon wieder sein bist und
ich gehören ja also ich kein bock noch
jungen aber nicht nur der politik über
dieses thema herrscht darüber könnte ich
das meine ich ganz ernst wirklich eine
sondersendung hatten wir viele sonne
sendung das thema kinder 1 was mir ganz
könnte mich zu überreden und klara gab
es versäumen dass er die unverzeihlich
sind
das ist also wie gesagt das ist ein
thema wirklich für eine sondersendung
und ich glaube da hätten wir alle sehr
viel zu berichten was was da unser herz
berührt